[Applaudissements]
non
oui
c'est lui c'est vraiment lui c'est
acapulco quoi on m'a dit fais simple
j'aime beaucoup ça la halle et moins
chiant d'avoir tout ce qui s'est passé à
la téloche bien entendu hier je crois
qu'il va faire conclut exactement oui on
a fait la connaissance de philippe venu
vendre un bijou de famille très très
rare une montre de collection fort et
philou il mise tout sur cette montre qui
compte bien vendre une blinde pour se
sortir d'une période un peu difficile
ah ben on va voir cette montre est une
montre quand même assez rare
on la trouve pas et en plus c'est un
grand modèle qui a été fait en peu
d'exemplaires je vais être très
difficile en affaire parce que j'attends
quand même appris à ses conséquences
tellement prudent qui m'a été offert par
les parents alors on résume montres
rares peu d'exemplaires prix conséquent
offertes par ses parents donc valeur
sentimentale a les filous on croise les
doigts et t'inquiète pas les experts ils
savent ce qu'ils font est ce que ça
existe encore des bandits dont attend à
cette fin il s était classé par an alors
mais j'ai complètement six jours d'écart
ça va moins bien marché mais lui c'est
un expert donc il a forcément des
techniques d'experts pour réparer ce
genre de choses c'est énorme
il faudrait peut-être commettre un bout
de scotch peut-être pas complètement
cassé il ondule a payé au prix fort bien
entendu au maximum bah oui ou non ils
sont payés jusqu'au dessus je sais pas
quoi ils seraient payés l'estimation sûr
mais oui ils ont évidemment mais voulait
vendre à 900 euros et ils ont payé 800
euros non c'est bien sinon payet aubry
c'est une grosse montre à la pâte et
part avec mokhtar lamhene bouée
un quota en plus et la femme de vos
stars il vient d'avoir avec moctar bien
sûr un baby le lit la femme qui a
accouché la semaine dernière le bébé se
portent bien il fait 17 kg c'est l'heure
du zapping du café au café au carnaval
dandy couple parfait quand quelqu'un que
tout le monde apprécie se fait éliminer
bas ça fait toujours de la peine je suis
quand même triste et voilà ça me fait de
la peine que no kill on est passé chez
elles ou d'autres heures pour un petit
contrôle de routine
i / hémorroïdes accès il ne faut pas
souffrir en silence
j'ai un petit problème non je vais vous
montrer parce que m
aujourd'hui le docteur est consacrée au
dollar de l'anus dans télématin on n'a
pas le droit de fourche et une seule
fois sinon on s'en prend plein la gueule
voici la situation donc pour demain même
d'alger avec un temps qui reste nuageux
voyage vous voyez un peu plus nuageux à
l'est et au centre et je vais m'arrêter
là
merci dans les z'amours un candidat
oublier un petit truc sur le bord de la
route
dès 10h 16h votre carton elle est partie
sur ce jour vous avez oublié jennyfer
mais heureusement son mac y avait quand
même une bonne excuse ça arrive
poser la question est-ce que c'est sexy
quelqu'un qui porte un jeans la réponse
c'était sur planète plus qui ça c'est
sexy quelqu'un qui porte un jean samuel
paquet le panier le burrito sa mine avec
nathalie marquay qui était sur le
plateau de thé ppr pour le mot de la fin
on va tous baiser
la beauce à sainte anne et bien sûr
nathalie amour que magnifique
alors est-ce que vous avez déjà testé
les lunettes de réalité virtuelle
ouais c'est chaud parce qu'on en fait tu
as l'impression que tu es là mettez pas
la déplacer ça fait comme dialecte
sombre associe qui va venir nous voir
vianney mars et mai ce qui est à venir
nous voir bientôt la peine si on l'adoré
sortie avec mon ex donc ils sentaient
que votre ex vianney tu peux nous parler
les équipes du mac de la santé sont
tannés dans sa vertu elle avait une
personne sache et déjà les autres est qu
une fuite dans la campagne fut la
campagne fidèle à kpatcha bien on est
rural on est attaquant peut donc à
prendre avec la compagnie avec vous que
j'ai un copain alors les équipes du mec
de la santé sont partis dans un ehpad et
ils ont rencontré jeanine 86 ans j'ai
été bluffé par cette technologie c'est à
la fois touchant et impressionnant vous
allez voir
[Musique]
j'aime il est confortablement installé
dans son fauteuil
[Musique]
jan ullrich on me réclame beaucoup dans
la chronique de luigi c'est le tarif du
jour c'est sûr qu'on a trouvé autour de
la table tour de france ils sont
indispensables au bon déroulement de la
compétition grâce à leur dextérité et
leur savoir faire
ces travailleurs de l'ombre on les
appelle les oeufs dtc qui sont les
effluents de table le pas lors de jours
il a beaucoup de talent
[Musique]
pour maman
je vais faire deux jeunes filles en tout
[Musique]
on a fait un petit bout alors on y va
allez c'est parti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis fan faire une autre y sont
géniaux et bravo bravo à toi tu es un
génie du bien génie lui alors qu'il
serait poser des questions voilà vous
aimez la bagarre sarah grabuge
l'assistanat et la paix je termine
carotide sérotypes s'est terminée merci
au revoir
vous l'avez jamais de bagarre jamais un
jour je vais vous dire
l'humour et la bienveillance et mon
maître mot jamais jamais jamais la
bagarre est jamais évident et même les
enfants qui l'on garde les parents ne
sont jamais des regards janet j'ai moi
c'est quoi l'histoire mais moi j'aime
bien ça dans les films d'action voile
avec dans les films et sa fille emma bon
coup de pied sauté une droite un salto
dans le film voilà je suis tombé sur une
scène de folie un coup de pression
suivies d'une claque de malades alors
vous allez me dire oui c'est un film de
van damme alors pas du tout c'était dans
au nom de la vérité
non j'adore ça en plus maintenant c'est
ton tour
non mais si je refusais nord et là c'est
mon papy
résumé retoqué j'étais pas venu roger
profuse qui tombe
on
s'attaque à t ai jamais bagarre laisse
deviner jamais les bras devant ledit axe
et l'oréal
[Applaudissements]
tout